Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Star Trek Picard Episode 2
video. There were a whole bunch of
Easter eggs for a classic Star Trek next
generation, the next generation movies so
if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes!
Obviously careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the episode yet, because
we'll be talking about everything. We'll
do top 10 in Easter eggs as we
go along starting with number 10 the
Utopia Planitia shipyards flashback they
show us what we thought was the
synthetic revolt that happened 14 years
ago part of the big catastrophe that
caused Picard to leave Starfleet it
didn't go down quite the way I expected
it to there are a couple things I think
that they haven't revealed yet but
they're just kind of laying seeds that
they'll reveal later on in the series we
find out they were using armies of
androids that all look very similar to
data like they were based on data and
before to work the shipyards it makes
sense they have some exposition that
reminds you just how much faster smarter
more powerful they are than normal
humans there's a real big Star Trek
first contact Easter Egg when the human
workers complained that they have to
work on first contact day while the rest
of the Federation gets the day off which
is obviously a reference to Star Trek
the first contact movie the day that
Vulcans officially made first contact
with humans via Zefram Cochrane they
reference it on a bunch of different
Star Trek series the f8 Android they
introduced acts a lot like data from the
Star Trek next generation pilot episode
encounter at Farpoint not understanding
jokes at all there's a reference to the
replicator technology una matrices are
something they referenced during the
short treks episode by Spock on the
enterprise
right before f8 seemingly revolts we see
his eyes look like they're processing
some sort of code update or an upload I
think that's just a seed that they're
laying like maybe something happened
someone tried to reprogram them so that
they would revolt maybe this is part of
the Josh plan whatever the case is it's
not just a simple revolt it's not like
they suddenly turned on their masters
with no cause somebody seems like they
were manipulating the androids to do
this the actual revolt itself was also
featured in the short treks episode
called children of Mars but f8 kills
everyone reprogram the orbital defense system
to fire on the planet
it causes all the
casualties number 9 we learned that
Picard's companions are former members
of the Romulan Tal Shiar secret police
but as laris corrects him on a bunch of
his assumptions about the inner workings
of Romulan military they'll culture
their technology their forensic methods
the title of the episode is called maps
and legends that's a reference to a
couple different things one of them
being the many different legends about
the history of the Romulan culture but
also a literal reference to the legend
part of a map which is the section of a
map that helps you decode the symbols on
each map later picard uses the Romulan
forensic technology to slowly build
himself a map it's not quite done yet
to Soji's character they don't know that
she's on the Borg cube yet so I'm
assuming they're going to learn that in the
next couple of episodes Laris also named
drops Romulan ale and the Gorn's which
she talks about the Gorn hegemony
she also jokes that only the Tal Shiar
could protect him from the other
Romulans in Tal Shiar so I think that he
just helps save them during the big
Romulan catastrophe in the supernova and
that's why they're with him now
number 8 the shot Vash the double
secret Romulan police so just as the
title of the episode was about legends
she explains the legend of the Romulans
version a basically Baba Yaga the
boogeyman that the Romulans would tell
new recruits about to scare them but it
kind of sets the stage for one of the
big battles this season like what's
going on behind the scenes who's really
trying to pull these strings the shot
Vash had this plan to eliminate all
synthetic life from the galaxy or
apparently that's always been their goal
they must have hated data back in the
day but Lawrence explains that the
organization has been around for
centuries operating from the shadows
since the dawn of artificial
intelligence in advanced computing the
Romulan society but that's who narak is
working for the Romulan we met last week
who's trying to work Soji on the Borg
cube number 7 Picard meets his old
shipmate from the stargazer there were a
couple stargazer references in episode 1
dr. Benny Yoon I think he's the only
other crew made of Picard's other than
Wesley crushers father that we've met
that was also on the stargazer he's
talked about the stargazer a lot during
next generation episodes but we never
really met a lot of the other crew
members from that ship he drops a big
reference to the Star Trek next
generation series finale - all good
things he says Picard has a flare up
issue in his parietal lobe
we found out during the series
finale in those flash forwards when it was
the older version of Picard on his
vineyard just like he is during this
series the syndrome caused him to have
all kinds of visions and eventually they
were going to wind up killing him so the
doctor is basically telling him that
this is going to kill you very soon so
hopefully your adventure will kill you
first the old doctor visiting him to
certify him fit for duty is also a nice
callback to bones from original Star
Trek visiting Kirk to diagnose him
before another big adventure number six
Picard goes back to Starfleet
headquarters in San Francisco everyone
probably recognized the classic Star
Trek theme song notes playing mixed with
a little bit of the theme song from Star
Trek The Next Generation as he stepped
through that transporter if you've ever
been to a convention in Anaheim you also
probably recognize the Anaheim
Convention Center that they used to film
this episode is serving as the facade
for Starfleet when he steps into the
building there are a bunch of holograms
above cycling through the various
versions of the enterprise and then they
have that funny joke the desk clerk not
recognizing him because he hasn't been
around in forever it's a bit of a meta
joke also about Patrick Stewart in real
life not having done Star Trek and so
long like wait a minute who are you
again what's your name whole bunch more
next gen Easter eggs so when he visits
the Admiral Clancy
she's actually a former crew
member from the enterprise who is an
incident during Star Trek The Next
Generation and it's played by the same
actress who came back obviously in real
life she's much older now so they both
look much older so when they say they
haven't always seen eye to eye it's
implied that later in their careers when
they had risen through the ranks they
had problems with each other she's
portrayed as more of a tragic character
than I think an antagonist she flat-out
denies his request for reinstatement
under the pretense that all of
Starfleet's decision about who lives who
dies what they did during the Romulan
incident is to keep the federation
together so even though she comes off
like a villain she's not trying to be
evil picard just feels like the
situation is much simpler all life is
precious they don't get to make the
choice about who lives and who dies if
you've been keeping track they also
dropped the second and third f-bombs
ever heard during any Star Trek series
in history or any movie the very first
f-bomb ever uttered on any kind of Star
Trek program was during Star Trek
discovery this past year number 5
all the next generation shout outs he
references Worf
LaForge Riker Beverly Crusher all his
former senior officers who are still
alive he says he doesn't want to burden
them because they'd sacrificed
themselves at the drop of the Hat out of
loyalty to him putting themselves in
grave danger
but speaking in a very meta way this is
also how the writers and the producers
justify not having all the original
next-gen cast members guest-starred
during season one really good example
this they've talked about bringing Worf
back Beverly Crusher during season two
but as far as I know Riker and Troy are
the biggest ones coming back during
season one but like this episode with
the Admiral and in future episodes
there'll be a ton of minor characters
coming back from next-gen so if you've
been watching next-gen recently or if
you're just a hardcore fan you'll
probably recognize a lot of these people
number four the Rafi character that he
goes to ask help for is a former
colleague from the Romulan incident who
ran into trouble with Picard and kind of
got thrown under the bus so that's why
she hates him so much he brings a huge
Easter Egg with him the 1986 Chateau
Picard bottle of wine 1986 is a
reference to the first season of Star
Trek The Next Generation which actually
didn't air until 1987 but October 1986
is when Gene Roddenberry made the first
official public announcement that they
were bringing Star Trek back and doing
Star Trek The Next Generation she's
going to be one of the other new main
characters this season there's still a
couple of big ones they just haven't
debut yet in episodes the place where
she lives is also a deep cut for classic
Trek it's called Vasquez rocks that's
the place in Southern California in real
life where they filmed Kirk fighting the
Gorn Picard makes a huge Isaac Asimov
joke when he's speaking to Allison
pihl's character oh you like the
classics the Isaac Asimov book she's
reading is also a reference to the Three
Laws of Robotics rule number one never
harm a human which i think is meant to
link it back to the beginning of the
episode in the flashbacks when we saw
the androids revolt on Utopia Planitia
remember I said though it's PI not that
simple there's place something else
going on behind this quote-unquote
revolt like maybe the Josh was secretly
reprogramming them number three on the
board Q we learned what it is if the
Romulans had been doing salvaging Borg
technology in it's all primarily a
Romulan operation but it's kind of joint
with the Federation because this is
really big treaty but it's the Borg cube
that followed Captain Janeway through
the wormhole
into the Alpha Quadrant in the Star Trek
Voyager finale it wasn't totally clear
where the cube came from until this
episode they explained that it's
technically been dormant for about the
last 16 years or so the collective
severed their link to it and each of the
surviving drones went into stasis the
whole thing is is they'll reactivate if
you get too close so they make a couple
references that during the episode they
refer to a gray area to stay away from
all the badges that they wear or meant
to mask their signatures from the Borg
drones and technology I think that's
just to let you know that they're
probably going to be some quote-unquote
accidents in future episodes and there
might be one or more assimilations
because there's a very notable sign that
says over 5,000 days since the last
assimilation I feel like that's the
writers telling us that there's probably
going to be in assimilation sometime in
a future episode number two though big
reveal the secret Romulan shot Vash plot
within the Federation wouldn't be a Star
Trek series if there wasn't some secret
plot within the Federation so like I
said the former crew mate Admiral that
Picard spoke to isn't overtly meant to
be a villain but clearly there are other
elements within Starfleet that are far
more insidious primarily talking about
the Commodore who may or may not also
secretly be a Romulan trying to look
like a Vulcan because there's a lot of
Vulcan stuff on her desk so I think
outwardly she's supposed to be a Vulcan
but because her underling is also a
Romulan disguised to look like a human
she also might be disguised to look like
a Vulcan it seems like their long-term
plan is to stop synthetics from
prospering around the galaxy but if
she's working with the Shot Vash or if
she's a member of the Josh and she's a
Commodore it would have taken her years
and years to rise to the ranks in
Starfleet
so either the Commodore just shares
their goals and they're temporarily
aligned or she is also secretly a
Romulan plant that just rose through the
ranks in Starfleet over the course of 30
or 40 years like I said her subordinate
has been permanently surgically altered
to look human she's being played by
Peyton List, you might recognize that
actress from the flash she played golden
glider
she was also poison ivy on Gotham she's
also revealed to be the sister of Ethan
Peck's Narek Romulan character and they're
the ones behind the Romulan strike team
that killed dodge in episode 1 and are
now trying to get her sister soji but
number one big we learned what the
josh's secret plan is why the
doing all this stuff while they're
trying to get Sochi why they
accidentally killed dodge when they were
really trying to capture her to
interrogate her is because they're
searching for what they think is a nest
quote-unquote they call it a nest with
many more copies of purely biological
androids
just like them it seems like they think
that Maddox created a bunch of other
Androids in secret somewhere they just
don't know where he is they're trying to
find him just like Picard is also trying
to find him so the plot thickens I love
all the Borg stuff that they're doing on
the show but let me know in the comments
if you spotted any big Star Trek Easter
eggs that I didn't mention in the video
episode three is going to be next week so
everyone and click here for my Star Trek
Picard Episode 1 video and click here
for my brand-new Marvel eternals teaser
breakdown thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!